[Music]
second Death Star's gone but the
imperial fleet is still at threat
Vanguard squadron let's make history
this is it Titan squadron
everything we've done has led to this
finish those bastards stop this is Star
Wars squadron earn your wings in a
single-player story spanning two
factions all stations and master
multiplayer battles as a squadron of
five with the option to play the entire
game in VR this is the definitive Star
Wars pilot experience
[Music]
you'll begin your career in a single
player story
welcome to titan squadron where you'll
play as two combat pilots flying for
both the Empire and the New Republic
you'll experience this world through
your cockpit the instrumentation in
front of you provides critical feedback
about power management targeting and
shields with a squadron of diverse
characters at your side prove your
skills on increasingly challenging
missions Vanguard
welcome to the nadir Dockyard one of my
spies has linked the attacks with the
New Republic star Hawk project the story
of the two pilots you playing stick
together will shape the balance of power
in the galaxy to take the fight online
you'll need flight time with all eight
ship's fighters are the most flexible
and versatile able to handle any
situation
interceptors are fast and highly
manoeuvrable let's get a ideal for
hunting down your opponent's
starfighters support ships can keep
allies safe and stocked up as well as
disrupting enemy fighters farmers are
the heavy hitters able to deal
devastating damage to enemy flag ships
and star fighters if you've got a
preferred component you need something
customized I'll take care of it unlock
everything you need to customize your
pilot and star fighters simply by
playing the game from cosmetics to an
arsenal of over 50 components that alter
how your ships fly fight and survive
I'll deal with it you can dramatically
change your loadout depending on your
squadron strategy finally got up this
will be critical in star wars squadrons
multiplayer modes first up dogfights
this is an all-out 5v5 fine-tune your
loadouts to work as a team moving in on
the enemy utilize
like tractor beams turrets and mines to
slow down your opponents or set up your
squadmates for the kill for teams
looking for an even greater challenge
it's time to prove yourself in Star Wars
squadrons signature mode fleet battles
fleet battles are multistage conflicts
whether playing solo or with friends
you'll have the option to compete
against other players or AI as a
squadron of five don't worry I got it
for you
meet your team in the social hub to
solidify a strategy coordinate loadouts
and prepare for takeoff
first push the frontline by winning the
dogfight in the center of the map
next attack or defend to medium-size
capital ships
we've lost our capital ships and finally
the ultimate goal target and destroyed
the subsystems of your opponent's
massive flagship and take it down at
each phase your squadron either pushes
the line forward or falls back to defend
keep our flagship safe is your squadrons
choice of how to play stay together
strike quickly stealth and subversion we
need to hurry
a unified squadron is the key to victory
starwars squadron join the galaxy's
finest and make your mark
you other hope this galaxy
[Music]